hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over my
thoughts and predictions on the up and
coming chapters for this three deities
arc i'll mainly be focusing and like
talking about tirano and the brahmin
guys as they seem to be kind of the
forefront for where we at in the manga
currently and if you guys want me to
make more like weekly prediction videos
kind of similar to this then be sure to
let me know down in the comment section
as well as it's been pretty difficult
i'd say over these last two weeks to
find any kind of legitimate spoilers uh
for the manga as they kind of really
haven't been any floating around there's
only been people kind of trying to do me
or dupe other uh people who put spoilers
out but these fake panels i guess you
could say so on weeks where there's
obviously no spoilers and i'm not
contacted by the person who usually gets
legitimate ones from japan then i'll be
sure to make like kind of similar
prediction videos like this on where i
think the series will be headed because
it's kind of annoying getting to the
weekend for me and then realizing that
i'm not going to be able to have a video
to upload because i haven't been able to
find any spoilers or something like that
so if you guys want this then be sure to
let me know down below like i've just
said but anyway enough of that let's
move into this video so obviously
throughout the last chapter we got
south's backstory we learned that he was
originally born in japan but then
traveled with i think his mother to
these slums or to
the favelas in brazil and we find out
that in the favelas in brazil he's
raised by a man named dino from a young
age and becomes someone who expresses
himself through music and violence
especially as at the age of five he was
able to shoot and kill one of dino's
enemies for him or a few of the misses
in the chapter at least so what i'm
thinking or at least what i've thought
from the idea of toronto right there
being able to shoot and kill one of
dino's enemies initially is actually
that that could possibly be a
foreshadowing for someone else showing
up in his own gang and shooting him as
this kind of this dog eat dog lifestyle
i guess you could say inside his own
gang or that's kind of what he's growing
up and as we know we later find out that
just after that he ends up killing or
brutally beating to death uh died in his
bed so obviously that dog eat dog world
he ends up becoming the leader of the
gang and that's why other people in the
gang obviously think shooting takamichi
and shooting like draken per se will
give them a higher ranking in the game
because they believe killing people was
going to bring them closer to the top
but this could have all been spoken to
them by toronto obviously once he had
formed brahman over that year that he
you know like was building it up and
everything but yeah no it's extremely
interesting what i want to know is kind
of like obviously there was a time
period from the age i'm pretty sure when
he was 14 to the age of what he is now
i'm not even sure what age he exactly is
now if anyone does know be sure to let
me know in the comment section below
because i'm pretty sure it hasn't even
told us um he could
the funny thing right now if this man is
like 15 or 16 i'm going to lose my like
my because that that just wouldn't
make any sense to me man like he's
absolutely huge if it's only been like
say the year or two it's only been like
two years say since he's come back and
started living with his uh grandparents
then i'm totally not going to fall for
them and it just doesn't it does not
seem right this man's not been given a
correct birth year or something along
those lines it's just ridiculous but
yeah so i am wondering you know how many
years have passed and between him coming
back and starting to live in japan with
his grandparents and how long um before
he went to juvie and what did he end up
having to go to juvie for in japan you
know like he was already there before
the uh kanto martian incident so it's
quite interesting obviously all of the
backstories kind of have ended now so we
probably are throughout the next chapter
going to get a massive showdown or a
massive battle between all these legends
and this tyrant so it's going to be
awesome to finally see them actually you
know have a fight for the first time in
ages we've had like hits here and there
but we actually haven't had a proper
like fight really going on it's just
been i heard a lot of talking i hit a
lot of talking but i want to see some
you know like tenjiku arc uh esque type
battles right now i don't think that the
uh undefeatable duo of benkei and wakasa
are going to be able to beat toronto
even with the age difference we've just
been shown throughout this last chapter
that that doesn't really matter because
at the age of of 12 or whatever he was
he ended up killing his uh so-called
stepfather so obviously that's just try
to take away that age gap and pretty
much show that there's no age gap that
really matters for toronto because he's
such a brute uh force of a person who
can absolutely destroy anyone and
anything and his path to becoming the
strongest but enough of toronto for now
quickly we'll just go over to mikey i'm
extremely interested to wonder like what
maiki is going to do once these people
have been defeated is senju going to you
know like step in and try and defeat uh
toronto by herself or is mikey and
takamichi and the other guys all kind of
going to form up to try and defeat
tirano here that could be a huge
possibility with the idea of like
takamichi possibly you know like
reinvigorating mikey in a way to get him
back on track so that they can like
fight to take down this guy who's you
know possibly trying to kill all of the
old tomy members and he's starting with
dracon here it's just an idea or
something to go on but mikey like who
has just been standing there the entire
time has kind of given us no uh like
indication that he even knows that this
has happened to draken he's been asked
if he cares as i've said about in the
last few chapters with no regard or no
kind of reply that he even realizes
what's just happened and what's just
gone down so i'm extremely confused on
like where he is in his head at the
moment usually he will be out there
fighting with everyone as well kind of
showing how strong he is rallying
everyone on his side to fight and do
more but now he's just kind of letting
sanzu get out there and fight everyone
with weapons and do all the damage uh
himself which is extremely uh
interesting and something that i didn't
think would see from mikey well he kind
of stands cluelessly at the back there
so i'm really hoping takamichi can
somehow swell mikey to
change his like actions or change how
he's acting and get him to notice that
draken has actually passed or draken has
actually taken a lot of damage here and
possibly through that you know they
could end up fighting together to try
and take down toronto with both of them
perhaps even losing to him just a
possibility and while they're losing and
dying on the ground takamichi could
possibly shake hands with mikey that
there is obviously just a thought kind
of in a similar way to how takamichi and
nyosu passed away i know ken likes to
take a lot of stuff from other arcs or
it seems like he's taking a lot of stuff
from other arcs for this arc here
initially um so it would make sense if
there is some kind of big moment where
he has to go back to the future and as
i've said i i believe you know kazutori
has to be a part of this overall plan
and i never really knew how takamichi
was going to get to the point where he
was going to be able to shake mikey's
hand so that he could travel back to the
future and then try and fix things with
kazura but i think the idea of
mikey possibly losing while takamichi is
helping him in a fight and then they
both collapse to the ground with even
say torano you know pulling at a gun and
trying to shoot them both or trying to
kill takamichi and uh mikey because he
was losing the fight and then you know
he he goes back to his you know old ways
pulls out the gun just to to get the
upper hand because maybe that's
something that he's done in the past
before but obviously i don't have a clue
and i really really don't know this is
uh
absolutely insane and i can't wait until
this next chapter does come out in a
like day or two now um so i'm pretty
sure when you guys see this it'll be
like a day and a half when it does come
out i've got a lot of stuff in the pipe
works for videos at the moment that's
why you haven't you know seen as much
content from me but if you guys do want
to see more of these prediction videos
every single week then be sure to let me
know down in the comment section below
if not then in a couple of days you'll
have my all deaths and juju two kaisen
video out and the rest of the arcs for
tokyo revenge is explained will also all
be out in their own like kind of
separate videos and i'm also going to
split the jiu jitsu video up into two
videos itself kind of explaining all of
the uh cursed spirit and all of these
sorcerers in their own videos as well so
you guys have got i guess all of that to
look forward to up and coming in the
next week along with if you guys want me
to i'm going to you know catch up on
demon slayer now that it's actually
releasing i'm going to watch the movie
and then catch up on the season to get a
little bit more of that information that
they possibly missed you know from the
manga and then i'm going to read the
latest arc that is currently out and
catch up on that and then i'm going to
do some videos on demonstrator for you
guys as well if you are interested in
that so be sure to let me know down in
the comment section below so a lot of
stuff uh coming up in the future but
i've only got so much time so i can only
do so much at a time i guess you could
say but yeah anyway i hope you guys have
enjoyed the video and if you do enjoy my
stuff then be sure to hit that subscribe
button as i really really appreciate it
and it helps out more than you guys
could imagine same with hitting that
like button but anyway enough of that
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
enable bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you